tell us about being an icon right
Kanye West is known for sparking
conversations and 2018 has been no
exception et is taking a look at the
rapper's wildest moments of the year
starting with his return to Twitter
after deleting his social media accounts
in May 2017 following wake kim
kardashian paris robbery the rapper
returned to twitter with a vengeance in
April 2000 a teen and tweeted about
virtually everything including his
polarizing political views and support
for president Trump you know why when I
went to visit him the first time right
after the election yeah and I took the
tweets down and everything done cuz I
was drugged gap bro I was addicted to
opioids
this brings us to May and the 41 year
olds totally bizarre rant on TMZ live
complete with an unexpected health
update I got liposuction because I
didn't want Charter called me fat like
y'all call Rob at the wedding and made
him fly home before me and Kim got
married I don't want y'all to call me
fat so I got liposuction right and they
gave me opioids he also ignited a
firestorm with his comments about
slavery are you here about slavery for
400 years for 400 years that's not like
a choice TMZ producer van Lee thin shut
down that idea real quick
stand on all the coffee tables you want
to stand on say whatever you want to say
but don't throw a stone didn't hide your
hands like the rest of us are just gonna
swallow it
yay BJ in August Kanye appearing on
Jimmy Kimmel Live where he addressed the
TMZ ran what was awesome is that the
world got to really experience someone
in a ramped up state and that's when you
get these comments that just shoot out
like almost like Tourette's while he
seems calmer and somewhat more composed
on Kimmel the rapper still made some
off-the-wall comments I actually white I
quite enjoy when people actually are mad
at me about certain things you want I
enjoy it yeah I actually quite enjoyed I
wasn't fool yeah I don't know if I'm
phool you now a better or worse whatever
then the late night host left his guests
speechless you so famously and so
powerfully said George Bush doesn't care
about black people it makes me wonder
what makes you
think that Donald Trump does or any
people at all in September Kanye gave
two bizarre performances during the
season 44 premiere of Saturday Night
Live I'm a real freak I need a real
freaking I'm a real freak I need a real
freak or should we say threes if you
count the unexpected pro-trump rant at
the end of the show in other news from
that day on Saturday September 29th
Kanye formally changed his name from
Kanye to just yay via Twitter yeah that
happened and the next day yay decided to
educate the Twittersphere even further
sharing this photo of him rocking a
maggot with the caption this represents
good and America becoming whole again we
will no longer outsourced to other
countries we build factories here in
America and create jobs
we will provide jobs for all who are
free from prisons as we abolish the
Thirteenth Amendment message sent with
love Kanye then took his support a step
further with a trip to the White House
it was something about when I put this
hat off and maybe you feel like Superman
the rapper is 10 minute long meeting
even let the president confuse
Constitution is the face of our industry
right our cut of our country of our
company would you feel happy you fall
and you end up so well 2018 may be
coming to an end we can't wait to see
what gay has in store for next year
[Music]
[Applause]